okay let's go next - where do we want to
go next let's go to the two one three
area code collar from two one three
what's on your mind who's this three
yeah that's you oh wow oh okay it's my
phone number anyway I have two questions
one is kind of long so I'll just give
you some adjustment at it for later this
one's a lot better for the show you
touched on this a bit before and I
wanted you to comment on it or the media
coverage for Bernie Sanders last year I
think they're able to do a little bit
more against him because he was so late
to the election you know like yeah his
name recognition wasn't out there but
this years I got a really gonna do it
for this long life what are some of the
ways that you think they're gonna try to
do it like for week I got four and I've
noticed you know like new people online
popping up with their own news and stuff
like that like some of the things so
they've got four ways we can combat that
and you know like I'm sorry I'm having a
hard time understanding what how is
Bernie going to be smeared this time
versus in 2016 you're saying it's like
how are they here to keep it up to the
election like for this long they were
able to keep it up last time because you
know he was late to the election you
know but this time he's early
everybody's early are they gonna like
block his coverage for like a whole year
and a half no I don't think so no no so
listen Bernie Sanders is the
front-runner on the Democratic side
right now so I did a sale but you
wouldn't know if I watching yeah yeah so
on the basis of polling name recognition
and fundraising I think it's undeniable
that Bernie's the front-runner right now
if there's going to be an establishment
move against Bernie and they're probably
already sort of is but it's not it's not
super large right now it's probably
going to be an argument along the lines
of number one a lot of other candidates
share a lot of Bernie's positions now so
his positions are no longer unique in
the way that they were in 2016 and
therefore since his positions are
similar to many other candidates does it
make sense to vote for the set
something year old white guy rather than
bringing in someone else with a
different identity does it make sense to
vote for the guy who's not even really a
Democrat is another way that they'll say
it so I think that that's going to sort
of be the frame the anti Bernie framing
for 2020 well I plan to get that because
you know they've already started doing
some of that but like what I mean it's
like he true like those huge crowds at
his rallies and it hardly got any
coverage like 30 seconds unlike NBC or
something like that you know like how
long can he keep that up like not
covering like what would you know they
know you know I don't over the weekend I
don't know exactly how much coverage
Bernie's rally got but I am not even
seeing that he is getting sort of like
iced out I'm not seeing that right now
but soon we should have data about how
much time each network is devoting in
terms of coverage to each candidate but
I'll keep an eye on it and report back
to you once we have more information
yeah I'm already seeing a little pattern
I'm hoping and I find doing kids he's
found a way through a lot of the set of
questions that they brought to him you
know and but I really hope he finds a
way around like the non coverage he's
been getting you know yep I will follow
it and will absolutely report on it I
appreciate the call thank you very very
much